CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was homeland
security and counterterrorism adviser to
President George HW Bush she joins us
Fran was this a national security
decision or a political one well you
know with the little that we know right
from what the president has said he
unilaterally revoked the clearance
I think that's unprecedented normally
clearances if they're revoked or laps to
go through a very formal bureaucratic
process the fact that the president did
this himself leaves him open to the
criticism that it looks politically
motivated and there seem to be a variety
of reasons for why he did this we heard
from Sarah Huckabee Sanders one set of
reasons then the president told the Wall
Street Journal while it was because
Brennan was associated with the Russia
investigation what does that mean to you
well look this is a many of us former
senior officials maintain our security
clearances because we volunteer our time
back to the government I sit on a
government advisory board I couldn't do
it without my clearance and it's you
don't this is not a professional
courtesy as the White House has
suggested we do this out of a sense of
public continuing public service and so
the notion that you're gonna pull
somebody's clearance because you don't
like what they did in government service
or you don't like what they say is
deeply disturbing and very offensive
frankly and it seems to have gotten very
personal you we heard the president
called John Brennan a lowlife he called
Omarosa a low-life never a good thing
John Brennan has also been very personal
against the president what concerns you
most about this you know the president
did this personal using his article what
we call his Article two powers as
commander in chief let's be honest if if
the president is relying on his Article
two powers to remove a clearance it's
the same power he'd rely on if he wanted
for example to fire Muller and so we
ought to understand that the president's
very expansive view of his powers is
constitutional powers he seems to have
an unlimited view of how expansive
they're going back to your point about
the the typical protocol of such a thing
takes place we though reports the dan
coates the head of the DNI was not made
aware of this prior to the president
deciding to do this do you think dan
coates at this point should step down
well look I mean each each cabinet
official each political appointees got
to make a personal decision
dan coates I have a tremendous amount of
respect for but you know you
have to feel if you're dan coates
undermined right into your own authority
right Fran thank you thank you